الان مع هذه الصور التي تظهر قصفا عنيفا
على منطقه الصفطاوي في
[موسيقى]
غزه يعني منذ ساعات الصباح قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي تواصل قصفها الجنوني المدفعي
وبطائق الحربيه في منطقه الصفطاوي هذه
غاره على مربع سكني كامل كما تشاهدونه
الان في منطقه الصفطاوي شمال مدينه
غزه ايضا هناك اشتباكات تدور في الناحيه
الغربيه من هذا الحي بالاضافه الى
اشتباكات اخرى تدور في حي الشيخ رضوان
الملاصق
[موسيقى]
له
يعني منذ ساعات الصباح قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي تواصل قصفها الجنوني المدفعي
وبطائق الصفطاوي هذه غاره على مربع سكني
كامل كما تشاهدونه الان في منطقه الصفطاوي
شمال مدينه
غزه ايضا هناك اشتباكات تدور في الناحيه
الغربيه من هذا الحي بالاضافه الى
اشتباكات اخرى تدور في حي الشيخ رضوان
الملاصق
له
[موسيقى]